and on a happy note
what happy note you're not the only one
married
what do you mean
what are you talking about we're married
how does that how does this work so you
did it
official during the quarantine yeah yeah
quarantine style
what the hell just happened in
quarantine
i'm literally down the hall from her why
didn't she call anybody
i mean she could have face-timed us wait
wait
so well you know we always wanted to do
like a beach ceremony but because of the
quarantine and everything that's
happening with the pandemic we didn't
really want to risk having everybody
or invite everybody i choose yeah it was
like all or nothing
so we found an officiant to come marry
us in the apartment
social distance he came it was just me
and florian and they came inside
he came inside we had the room decorated
in candles and
i wore my dress it was like my own
cinderella moment it was crazy
why did you keep it from us like why
it's creeping for a monster oh i tell
everybody or or tell everybody
how you felt i kind of felt like the
last time we left off it was you were
kind of upset with florian and me and i
didn't really need the negative feedback
you